so what I want to do here is have a
conversation about the original Wally
West and what I'm hoping is that at the
end of all this you'll have a strong
understanding of his character as well
as why fans prefer this version to the
one scene in the new 52
so Wally West first appears in DC Comics
with the flash Volume one issue number
110 in 1959 and was created by John
Broome and carmine infantino considered
to be the one true version of Wally West
as opposed to his new 52 counterpart the
love of fans hafir Wally is the result
of his involvement in the flash series
and the expansion of the mythos during
his time as the title character coming
out of DC success with Dick Grayson his
Robin in 1940 couple with the
introduction of several more sidekicks
in the form of Roy Harper from the Green
Arrow series and Bucky Barnes from
Marvel's captain America the desire of
DC at the time was to introduce a
counterpart to the flash comics in a way
that would help to boost sales and drive
interest from younger readers however
with the flash series incorporating
multiple stories confined within a
single issue because DC was hesitant to
see Wally introduced to readers who
would reject the idea of a sidekick
instead the introduction of Wally came
as a backup feature in issue number 110
titled meet Kid Flash now in his first
appearance while he's brought before
Barry by iris West with a story actually
taking place before iris becomes aware
of the fact that Barry is the flash
instead iris is under the impression of
the two were close friends and because
Wally is the president of the Blue
Valley flash fan club iris hopes that
Barry will introduce the two in grant
Wally's wish with iris departing and
allowing the two to spend time together
Barry sends Wally to his laboratory
under the guise that he'll get a chance
to meet the flash taking the momentary
distraction to change into his signature
uniform and race to the room before
Wally can enter Barry greets him as the
flash and even goes as far as to show
Wally how he gained his abilities
however the funding games go awry when
Wally's exposed to the chemical
combinations and struck by lightning and
the same exact fashion is Barry now
where this stretches credulity at best
and is clearly written for the sake of
simply turning Wally into the flash
something to remember here is that
during the 1950's readers focus less on
the how and why when it came to heroes
gained their powers because this was
during the early days of the Silver Age
and the resurgence of interest in comics
the concern of both fans and DC itself
was more on the order of cranking out
new heroes and simply seeing what became
popular and so after performing a couple
of experiments and testing the speed of
Wally because he seems for all intents
and purposes to be identical in power to
Barry while he's provided a red flash
costume similar to varies
and given the name Kid Flash now for
those of you who are new to my channel
when I first started producing content
one of the things that I had said was
that if I didn't know something I would
always be upfront and simply say that I
don't know in this instance regarding
Wally's publication history after his
introduction I don't really know
anything about his stories I know that
at some point is costume changed to a
yellow and red design and I believe he
was a member of the Teen Titans but
again if I can't verify something in a
comic book I don't consider it to be
true and because I can't locate comics
based on these stories
I'm not going to espouse them as
absolute fact instead what we're going
to do here is we're going to jump
forward to crisis on Infinite Earths and
wally west replacing Barry Allen as the
flash so by 1985 the stories of Barry
Allen had been struggling financially
and that while he continued to be a
relatively popular character in terms of
sales
he'd been lagging behind Superman Batman
and others for quite some time where the
decline wasn't large enough for DC to
drop the Flash series entirely it was
enough to raise a few eyebrows in
addition to this but the time crisis on
Infinite Earths came around the flash
reader base was largely composed of
Wally West fans who would quite
literally grown up with the character as
a result is seemed to be a natural
progression for Barry to move beyond the
flash character and for Wally to
undertake his mantle in his place to
this end when Marv Wolfman and DC had
launched crisis on Infinite Earths in an
effort to correct the continuity issues
that existed following the advent of the
multiverse with flash of two worlds the
reboot was used as a catch-all to
effectively kill off Barry Allen and set
the stage for Wally in issue number
eight after making a series of sporadic
appearances in the story from the state
of captivity Barry had broken free of
his prison at the hands of the
anti-monitor and began the process of
attempting to dismantle the antimatter
cannon which would have been used to
wipe out all life in existence where
Barry was successful in dispersing the
antimatter energies and sparing a
handful of universes from guaranteed
destruction the manner in which he died
with his essence simply fading away to
nothingness was an indication by Wolfman
but not only was very gone but there
have been no plans by DC to bring him
back using this as a jumping-off
platform at the conclusion of the series
with the anti-monitor defeated DC had
Wally step out of the Kid Flash persona
and into the main flash pool by adopting
the mantle in honor of very sacrifice
so following crisis on Infinite Earths
and wally west sufficiently becoming the
flash the title which we launched his
volume to in the form of a monthly
series underwriter Mike Baron and artist
Larry Moss Ted where Mike Baron had only
stayed on for about fourteen issues as
he was switched over to Marvel to write
for The Punisher within the first two
issues Baron had written a story
involving Vandal Savage attending to
hunt down Wally as a Golden Age villain
dating back to 1943 in an enemy of the
original Allen Scott when DC had created
the multiverse Vandal Savage crossover
into the main continuity and became an
enemy of the earth one Justice League as
well
however when crisis on Infinite Earths
happened rather than having his
continuity reset Vandal Savage was
continued on isn't nothing had happened
and instead became an enemy of Wally
with the intention of killing him along
with the rest of the Justice League
while this attempt was unsuccessful the
purpose of this story was to establish
that Wally was a credible threat to
villains in DC Comics rather than being
a publicity stunt furthermore in issue
number one Mike Baron had sought to move
Wally away from the life of struggling
financially and instead become an
overnight millionaire after winning the
lottery using this to create a subplot
of Wally attending to cope with his new
level of financial success coupled with
savage hunting him down and his efforts
in becoming a hero Baron was also faced
with the fact that there were still a
multitude of Barry Allen fans who had
stayed on board even after his death and
crisis on Infinite Earths in an effort
to ensure that those fans weren't
alienated but to also keep new fans
appeased Baron established that Wally's
powers regarding his speed were still
formidable but that he was a less
powerful version of Barry in this sense
Wally was able to run faster than the
speed of sound but he wasn't able to
move faster than the speed of light and
instead of functioning as a normal human
with SuperSpeed he had to consume
massive quantities of food in order to
keep his body from literally consuming
itself for energy were these stories
under Barron followed the theme of
comics at the time and focusing on more
realistic character driven content as
opposed to the light-hearted content
scene pre-crisis fans found that this
version of Wally was difficult to keep
up with and that Barron seemed to be
throwing out too much too fast in an
effort to keep interest and so following
his departure with issue number 14 in
1988 the series came under the control
of William Messinger loaves who wrote
for the series until issue number 61
where Barron had left the series with
plot threads involving the loss of his
powers and his relationship with key
McGhee a scientist who had been married
to Jerry McGee and gained a grant from
Harvard University to study the
metabolism of Wally where Baron had
Jerry become a villain named speed demon
by way of a chemical called compound 19
in an effort to provide Wally with his
own signature villain fans had largely
rejected the idea and within a couple of
issues Baron wrote Jerry into a coma
following a battle with Wally however
because the path read of Tina and Wally
engaging in a relationship was left
hanging when messenger Lopes took over
the series he revived Jerry restored his
sanity and put him back together with
Tina removing her as a love interest for
Wally during this time and with DC we
launching the Justice League post crisis
as an international team focus on
worldwide conflicts because while he
stood in a kind of middle ground
regarding his popularity among older
fans and potential popularity with newer
readers under Keith Griffin and J M
DeMatteis Wally was rolled over into the
new Justice League branch off group
titled Justice League Europe in an
effort to boost the popularity of its
initial launch but also exposed Wally to
existing readers who were otherwise
unsure about his character proving
itself to be a success and that while I
became a standout star of the series
Justice League Europe helped to fuel the
fire of his popularity which in turn
altered the sales of a solo comic in
addition to this for many fans
it wasn't until around a year into his
four-year run that Loubs had come into
his own with the flash stories and that
by issue number 28 Messer Lopes had
introduced Linda Park and in issue
number 32 wally was moved to Keystone
City arguably considered to be two of
the most important aspects of his
character the placement of Wally and
Keystone allowed for messler lobes to
begin the process of removing him from
the shadow of Barrie and the
introduction of Linda set the stage for
a future love interest and marriage
between the two
however when loaves departed the series
in 1992 with issue number 61 the title
was handed over to Mark Waid who's
considered to be the landmark writer for
Wally West as a relatively new writer at
the time with several titles under his
belt including Legion of super-heroes
Doom Patrol and Wonder Woman and 1987
Mark Waid has established a strong name
for himself after working alongside
Brian Augustine with Gotham by Gaslight
which went on to establish the DC
Elseworlds line of comics as a result
Augustine had hired wade on to take over
and continue the series however the
mishmash of paths reg from Barron &
Loubs had created a veritable nightmare
for newer readers who look to get into
the series and so the intention of wade
was to effectively start anew
essentially relaunch the flash series by
introducing new themes and create a
self-contained universe that expanded on
the existing content to this end with
issue 74 through 79 mark way to
introduce a six-part series title the
return of Barry Allen which introduced
the post-crisis eobard thawne because
we've covered this character several
times on this channel there's really no
reason for us to do it again but the
purpose of this story was to see the
return of eobard thawne but also move
Wally into his own what I mean here is
that in the eyes of Mark Waid and flash
fans as a whole if wally was going to be
the star of the story he needed to be
treated that way within both the DC
Universe and DC Comics as a whole as a
result at the conclusion of the story
and with Thawne and Wally engaging in a
battle it was revealed that while he had
the potential to be a more powerful
version of the flash than Barry was but
that he had simply been holding himself
back at a fear of offending Barry's
legacy using this new standard of
Wally's powers in that like Barry he
could now travel through solid objects
by vibrating and is occasionally able to
exceed the speed of light with issues
number 92 and 96 way to introduce Bart
Allen as a descendant of the Allen
family line from the 30th century and
Jesse quick the daughter of Golden Age
speedster Johnnie quick and go tan H
heroine Liberty Bell following up in
issues 97 through 100 with a story
titled terminal velocity Wade brought
together and reconciled the powers of
Max mercury Wally West Johnny quick
Jesse quick Bart Allen and Jay Garrick
by establishing that their ability to
move at SuperSpeed was rooted in a
concept called the Speed Force as a
singular source of energy existing
outside of the multiverse and uniting
all speedsters under its power the
introduction of the Speed Force came by
way of Max mercury who was established
to have previously been part of the u.s.
frontier and a friend to a local Native
American tribe however when the tribe
was ambushed by the militia mercury was
bestowed with the ability to move at
super speed allowing him to avenge the
Native Americans following this and
while using his super power
mercury constantly bumped up against an
invisible barrier which he couldn't
penetrate but emanated a vast amount of
energy attending to pass through it but
failing each time every attempt of match
to enter the Speed Force came with a
jump into the future which was used to
explain how he had survived for the 19th
century to the current day and so as the
final piece of the puzzle and in an
effort to make Wally a standalone
character issue number 99 settled into
park attack at the hands of a villain
named Cobra coming to her aid and moving
laughter than he ever had where while he
saved Linda's life he also vibrated at
the right frequency allowing him to
enter the Speed Force using this as a
jumping-off platform weight went forward
into the rest of his run establishing
that unlike Barry Allen and the rest of
the speedsters who tapped into the Speed
Force when they use their powers instead
Wally had effectively become part of the
Speed Force which enhances existing
abilities making him faster and more
powerful than Barry Allen as a result
fans were ecstatic to see Wally
officially moving out of the shadow of
Barry and into his own role as the top
flash of the time never Wally had found
success within the pages of his own
comic the drive of DC at the time was to
forge alliances between Wally and newer
heroes who were cropping up and
replacing some of the older characters
with Hal Jordan vacating his position as
the Green Lantern after eliminating the
core and killing off the guardians of
the universe during the events of
Emerald Twilight in zero-hour DC look to
establish legitimacy for the newly
created Kyle Rayner
by having him become friends with Wally
while the early means between the two
were tense and that while he had quite
literally grown into a superhero and
looked up to how as a role model
following the death of Barry Wally and
Kyle grew to become close friends with
DC introducing sever one-shot team most
between the two would serve to bolster
their popularity among fans now where
wise eight-year run ended in 2000 with
issue number 162 by issue number 164
fledging writer Geoff Johns was brought
on board to take over the title due to
his critically acclaimed work on the
newly reinstated Justice Society of
America from 1999 where John's continued
many of the trends that made Wally
popular under Wade and that he
maintained his ability to move faster
than Barry on occasion as well as his
connection to the Speed Force John's
also sought to expand on the existing
mythos and the life of Wally to this end
and flash issues 197 through 200 during
a story called blitz Jeff Jones
introduced the possibility of Wally and
Linda having children where issue number
198 saw hunter zolomon attacking Linda
and causing a miscarriage the comic
ended with walling and Solomon battling
one another and while a coming out on
top but because the comic was released
as a monthly series this allowed for
Jaws in DC to determine fan feedback
regarded the idea and move forward
accordingly with a company receiving a
slew of letters from fans requesting to
see Wally's family grow following the
conclusion of the Blitz storyline with
Linda's miscarriage and going into issue
number 225 solomon had returned
Walli with their battle raging across
the Timescape its conclusion sawwali
throwing zolomon in the wave is past
self during his attack on Linda the
result was that Linda was spared the
attack and when time corrected itself
she was nine months pregnant and giving
birth
however with Infinite Crisis launching
in 2006 as a way for DC to cope with
lingering continuity issues from crisis
on Infinite Earths the company looked to
use the opportunity as a way to
experiment with a replacement for Wally
West as a new flash and so using the
actions of Max mercury Johnny quick Bart
Allen and Wally West trapping
superboy-prime in the Speed Force as a
platformer DC segue into sending Linda
Park Wally
J and iris into a parallel earth leaving
Bart as the main flash on new earth
launching a year-long series called
flash the fastest man alive the goal of
having Bart Allen replaced while he
turned out to be a dismal failure with
both fan right hands and slumping sales
demanding the return of Wally as a
result while he was brought back as the
main star of the title along with Linda
giant iris but despite the success of
most of his stories including Wally's
focus on solving the problem of giant
iris his rapid aging it was no secret
that John's refer the characters of
years past
in the era they represented where fans
loved the work that John's was putting
in during his run regarding the Rogues a
group of flash villains who came
together and their attempts to defeat
him as well as the creation of hunter
zolomon the third person to undertake
the reverse-flash mantle by issue number
226 John's had left the flash title and
was replaced by a series of interim
writers including Stuart a moment Joey
Cavallari in addition to the return of
Mark Waid where these stories maintained
their popularity as they continued fan
favorite themes but also coincided with
Wally West's appearances in Justice
League and Justice League Unlimited
between 2001 and 2006 by 2009 Jones had
developed enough clout with NBC to
organize and see the return of Barry
Allen to the flash landscape where
Barry's initial return came during Grant
Morrison's 2008 event final crisis
center on dark sides attempt to
overthrow reality using the anti-life
equation at its conclusion John's
followed up with a story flash rebirth
which followed Barry adapting to his
life among the living where the story of
largely focused on retconning Barry's
history in relation to eobard thawne and
the various tragedies of Barry's life
for many DC fans the writing was on the
wall regarding Wally West and that while
he wasn't quite out of the game he was
certainly being handed as
and so the concern of DC fans ultimately
came to fruition during 2011 s
flashpoint storyline leading into the
launch of new 52 with Wally West Irish
Jay and Linda all being wiped from the
flash continuity and Barry Allen
standing as the only version of the
character with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end and
I will catch you guys later
whose